in previous videos we talked about the
emergence of the Maurya Empire around
322 BCE shortly after the invasion of
Alexander the Great as the first truly
great Indian Empire it unifies most of
the Indian subcontinent
now that Empire eventually Falls and the
next significant Empire to emerge
especially if we talk about influence on
India and the world is the Gupta Empire
which emerges over 500 years later now
let's zoom in on our timeline to get a
deeper appreciation of the Gupta Empire
it's believed that it start was with
Shree Gupta
he started the Gupta dynasty around 240
and it's disputed where they emerged it
might have been in that region or in
that region there's different accounts
of where the Gupta dynasty initially
emerged but even in the early 300s they
really had a control of a few small
kingdoms it wasn't until the reign of
Chandragupta the first that it becomes a
significant dynasty and we need to be
careful don't confuse this chandra gupta
the first with Chandragupta Maurya who
founded the Maurya dynasty over 600
years before the time we're talking
about chandra gupta the first it's
interesting because he is really able to
gain power not initially through
conquest but through a marriage he has a
marriage with the princess kumara Devi
and as a dowry he's given control over
much of this region of northeast India
this region of mugga dharma gutta and I
am always having trouble pronouncing
that so my apologies including the
famous city of potala patre which even
in the time of the Maurya Empire and
before the Maury Empire this was a
famous seat of power but once he's in
control of this region then he and his
successors are able to have increased
conquests over India you see in this
light
color what his son some would drag Gupta
was able to do and then one of some
would drag up the sons
chandragupta ii is able to conquer even
more but what makes the gupta empire
distinctive isn't just that they were
able to unify much or conquer much of
india again what really makes them
distinctive is because of that
unification and especially the wealth
that began to flow into the capital they
were able to be sponsors of significant
culture and science and the arts and
that's why historians view the Gupta
Empire as the Golden Age of India and
just to get an appreciation for this the
Gupta Empire was during the time of Kali
Das and he is considered to be the
greatest writer ever in the Sanskrit
language he is like the William
Shakespeare of Sanskrit beyond
literature and writing you have
significant contributions to science
most notably
Arya Botha he's known for a very
accurate approximation of Pi but even
more important a recognition that was an
approximation and that he potentially
recognized the irrationality of Pi one
of the first to do so the word sine the
trig function is derived from
aryabhata's word for that function and
so he established some of the early
ideas of trigonometry he did work in
summation he had did significant
astronomical work recognizing the
rotation of the earth at versus the
rotation of the heavens he had an early
concept of gravity even some of these
notions of the place value system and
zero and decimal notation many of our
modern notions of it are traced back to
RA abhava in other videos on the Islamic
Golden Age when we talk about folks like
Al car is me a lot of his work was based
on what he learned from Aryabhata
beyond the sciences and once again this
is just a sample of all that happened
during this period you have the
significant
Hindu epics the mahabharath the Ramayana
the Puranas get written down and
formalized you could say they were
canonized the game of chess or the early
version of the game of chess was
invented called chaturanga and they had
horsemen or which were the Knights they
had infantry which were the pawns they
had elephants which eventually turned
into bishops but as it migrated to
Persia the Muslim world and then into
Europe it became our modern game of
chess famously there's this iron pillar
that is now in New Delhi that is traced
back to the time of the Gupta Empire is
believed to the reign of chandragupta ii
and what's amazing about this this is a
this is a pillar that's over 20 feet
high made out of wrought iron and over
1500 1600 years it hasn't corroded and
has inscriptions on it that help
historians point to the Gupta Empire
this was some of the coinage of the
Gupta Empire so the big takeaway here is
this was India's Golden Age the
Classical period of India a lot of
modern Hinduism and Indian culture can
be traced back to this time period but
it isn't just its influence on India in
other videos we talk about the Islamic
Golden Age and much of that golden age
which emerges 2 3 400 years after the
time after the Gupta Empire Falls much
of that work is based on the discoveries
and the work that is collected during
the time of the Guptas and then that
becomes a bridge eventually to the
European Renaissance now like all
empires the Gupta Empire does eventually
fall in the mid 6th century it's
believed around 540 550 and one of the
main causes there's invasions cut from
people called the who-knows-who
historians believed are either the Huns
or a group that are closely related to
the Huns
it's considered to be one of the causes
of the eventual decline of the Gupta
dynasty